du blabla ces mots ce sont ceux de greta
tanberg la jeune militante écologiste
suédoises un coup de gueule poussé lors
de la cop 26 de glasgow une coop une de
plus avec ces avancées et beaucoup de
scepticisme et ça fait 26 ans que ça
dure aucune décision concrète n'est à
attendre de ce sommet de berlin aucun
enthousiasme beaucoup de chaises vides
le 18e sommet on en attend pas grand
chose 1995 direction berlin pour la
toute première coop ou conférence des
parties dix jours de discussions entre
dirigeants du monde entier pour parler
climat et à l'époque déjà les
journalistes étaient dubitatifs sur
l'utilité d'un tel rendez vous 160 pays
représentés au sommet de rio en 92 ils
ne sont qu'une centaine aujourd'hui à
berlin et les militants écologistes
n'étaient pas non plus très nombreux
quelques pauvres banderoles pour prendre
à témoin les délégués à la conférence
des nations unies sur le climat après la
copains la coque 2u l'a3 l'a4 l'a5 et à
chaque fois la même interrogation des
journalistes encore une conférence
diront certains on commence donc ce
journal par les pilotes d'un sommet qui
devait être celui de toutes les
décisions concrètes et qui semble
finalement n'être que celui des
promesses une nouvelle fois même
incertitude chez les politiques 2009
cop 15 à copenhague négociations confuse
interminable un accord est quand même
signé au bout de la nuit mais pas par
tous les pays même le premier ministre
danois du mal à s'expliquer
[Musique]
c'est c'est c'est un accord
il a été approuvé par 26 personnes 26
membres et je pense que d'autres
d'autres vont suivre rapidement
neuf ans plus tard en 2018 une jeune
fille tire la sonnette d'alarmé la coop
24 elle s'appelle greta tanberg n'a que
15 ans et son discours fera le tour du
monde vous prétendez aimer vos enfants
plus que tout et pourtant si vous volez
leur futur on n'est pas venu ici pour
supplier les chefs d'état de faire
attention on est venu vous dire que le
changement arrive que ça vous plaise ou
non
trois ans plus tard nouveau discours
donc de la suédoise lors de la cop 26 de
glasgow
une coop qu'elle qualifie d' échec
[Musique]